الى سمير نمري في الحديده سمير ما
المعلومات عن الغارات الامريكيه
البريطانيه التي جرت صباح اليوم في
الحديده نعم جلال بحسب مصدر عسكري في
جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين فقد تم شن عده
غارات جويه على محافظتي صعده والحديده هنا
في الحديده استهدفت الغارات الجويه معسكر
الجبانه وهو معسكر قد تم اخلاءه من الجنود
في وقت سابق وقد رض لعدد من الغارات بشكل
كبير خلال الفترات الماضيه كما تم استهداف
ايضا مواقع في محافظه صعده الحدوديه مع
السعوديه والواقعه شماليه ليمن بعدد من
الغارات لكن المصدر العسكري في جماعه
انصار الله الحوثيين قلل من هذه الغارات
وقال انها غارات عبثيه وانها لا تسبب ايه
خسائر سواء ماديه او بشريه وانها تستهدف
مواقع او
اراض ذات فراغ وغير ماهوله بالجنود او
المعدات هذا القصف الجوي الامريكي
والبريطاني ياتي فقط بعد ساعات من اعلان
جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين استهداف
السفينه التجاريه الامريكيه كول في خليج
عدن وفق الناطق العسكري فقد تم استهدافها
بصواريخ مناسبه وان الاصابه كانت مباشره
حذر الناطق العسكري في انصار الله
الحوثيين من ان التصعيد الامريكي
البريطاني على اليمن سيقابل بتصعيد من
داخل اليمن مماثل وان جميع القطع العسكريه
والاسلحه والمدمرات والبوارج والسفن
الامريكيه والبريطانيه الموجوده في البحر
الاحمر والبحر العربي وخليج عدن جميعها هي
اهداف ستصل صواريخ وطائرات انصار الله كان
وزير الدفاع في حكومه انصار الله قد اعلن
قبل يومين بان قواته قد استعادت ما سماها
اعاده انتشار العمليات وتقييم الوضع
العملياتي في البحر الاحمر وخليج عدن
والبحر العربي وان جميع هذه القوات سيتم
استهدافها متى ما شاءت ومتى ما تم التصعيد
الامريكي والبريطاني وما زال مستمرا من
المتوقع ان يلقي ايضا زعيم الجماعه عبد
الملك الحوثي خطابا او كلمه عصر اليوم
يحدد فيها مسارات المرحله المقبله وربما
يعلن عن مرحله جديده من التصعيد في ظل
استمرار القصف الامريكي والبريطاني على
اليمن هذا التصعيد المستمر ياتي بعد ايام
فقط من قيام قوات انصار الله الحوثيين
باستهداف سفينه شحن نفطيه بريطانيه في
خليج عدن واصابها اصابه مباشره مما ادى
الى احتراقها كما اعلنت الجماعه عن
استهداف عدد من السفن الامريكيه في وقت
سابق شكرا لك سمير في الحديده غرب اليمن
m